hirschsprung disease is a birth defect
in babies in which part of the large
intestine is unable to move waste
properly this causes a blockage in the
large intestine of a newborn baby the
large intestine includes the colon and
rectum after digested food moves through
the small intestine it enters the large
intestine
as it moves through the colon water and
salt are absorbed and solid waste forms
the waste enters the rectum which pushes
it out of the body through the anus
during a normal pregnancy nerve cells
travel down the developing nervous
system to the growing digestive system
including the large intestine these
nerve cells develop into ganglion cells
between the muscle layers of the large
intestine
the ganglion cells send nerve signals to
the muscle layers to contract and relax
these contractions are part of a series
of wave-like motions that push waste
along the length of the large intestine
in a newborn baby this movement pushes
waste along the length of the large
intestine toward the rectum and anus
if the developing baby has her sperm
disease these cells either don't reach
this area or don't become functioning
ganglion cells when they get there
when this baby is born a section of
large intestine does not have ganglion
cells it can also extend for a short
segment or a longer segment involving
the colon or rarely the entire colon
without ganglion cells to signal the
intestinal wall to relax this area of
the large intestine stays contracted and
narrow blocking the passage of waste and
gas as waste and gas buildup behind the
blockage the large intestine and abdomen
begin to swell the baby may develop an
intestinal infection called
enterocolitis then the intestine may
stretch further and cause vomiting and
nutrition problems a baby with
hirschsprung disease will need a
surgical procedure to remove the
diseased section of his or her large
intestine until the baby is ready to
have this procedure he or she will need
rectal irrigations this procedure will
help remove gas and waste several times
a day which helps prevent infection the
most common surgical procedure for her
sperm disease is called a
laparoscopically assisted trans anal
pull-through during the procedure the
surgeon will make three or four tiny
incisions in the baby's abdomen and
insert a thin lighted camera and special
instruments the surgeon will use these
instruments to loosen and remove the
diseased intestines attachments to the
body to remove the diseased intestine
the surgeon will make a circular
incision in the baby's rectum inside of
the anus then the surgeon will pull the
diseased intestine out through the
baby's anus and remove it
the remaining healthy intestine will be
sutured to the baby's anus this new
connection will form a tube that can
properly move waste out of the body at
the end of the procedure the surgeon
will remove the instruments and close
the abdominal incisions with sutures or
skin closure tape since most of the
procedure will be done through the anus
there will be no incisions to close
outside the anus